un voyage scolaire qui tourne mal avec
la cub de quatre élèves pour arthur
fanchon et les autres à l'ombre du vent
film de fiction c'est avant tout de bons
souvenirs cinq jours de tournage à
barcelone que ces apprentis cinéastes ne
sont pas prêts d'oublier
c'est une chance de partir à barcelone
une semaine pour faire un autre court
métrage encore mieux parce que c'est
quelque chose que j'adore faire jouer
devant la caméra sur une scène et c'est
donc à titre personnel c'est très
enrichissant
au total vingt-deux élèves ont mis la
main à la pâte
assisté de deux professionnels agronomie
et cinéma des univers plutôt éloigné n'y
a pas forcément de lien
vraiment proche moi je suis parti pour
faire une étude dans tout ce qu'est le
domaine de l'eau de l'environnement donc
réelle du tout fait rien à voir avec ces
domaines là mais c'est vraiment un sujet
qui me passionne qui m'intéresse
beaucoup et aujourd'hui dans ce
multiplex c'est le grand jour
les élèves en projeter leurs films mais
pas uniquement au programme il y a
également de la musique car détrompez
vous dans les lycées agricoles
il n'y a pas que l'agronomie on a
vocation justement à pousser les élèves
vers des domaines un petit peu
artistique puisque historiquement bas
les lycées agricoles c'était plutôt des
lycées où il y avait des garçons qui
étaient issus des milieux rural et c'est
vrai que c'était c'était pas mal
effectivement de les entraîner vers des
terrains qui ne connaissait pas du tout
cinéma musique arts plastiques plus
qu'un projet scolaire ces ateliers
permettent à ces jeunes de connaître
avant tout l'éventail de leurs
possibilités
[Musique]